[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together
we're the minimalists home ownership
versus renting what are the upsides and
downsides of each which option is better
for you what are the minimalist thoughts
on both
that's what we're talking about today on
this public edition of the minimalist
podcast then this thursday on the
minimalist private podcast we're going
to talk about 15 products that add value
to our lives are they minimalist
products you get to decide we'll also
talk about my new home that i just
purchased in a small town where is it
why am i moving there where else did i
consider living is this a permanent move
are bex and josh still living separately
that's what the questions they've been
asking also
are josh and ryan breaking up live on
the podcast you wish
[Laughter]
provide a chance ryan if you ever leave
me i'm coming with you
[Laughter]
so romantic you can check that out on
the private podcast
theminimalists.com
patreon to subscribe you'll get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app your support keeps our podcast and
youtube channel 100 advertisement free
because advertisements suck ryan let's
get to our first question right now from
mary over on patreon let's do it what
are the minimalist thoughts on renting
versus owning a home um ryan i
don't ever want to own a home
i don't want to ever rent a home ah
no here's here's the problem so for a
longest time i thought there was a right
answer to this yeah what is better right
is it better to rent or is it better to
own yeah and the answer to that is well
it depends 100
now let's talk about some of the factors
here
one of the factors is
how do i feel about home ownership now
me personally there's actually there's
this article ryan we're going to read on
the maxwell episode this week over on
patreon but i wanted to read point five
from this from our friend derek sivers
he talks about choosing the plan with
the most options for example renting a
house is buying the option to move at
any time without losing money in a
changing market 100 yeah you can turn
your life around on a dime pretty easily
if you're just renting and
there are times though like right now
where the housing market has been over
the course of the last year or two where
you could sell a house same day pretty
much yeah because of the market was much
more of a a seller's market right and so
there were multiple bids i went through
this myself recently as i was buying a
new home and it's weird because i don't
if it was just me i would never own a
home personally because exactly what
derek sivers is saying here i like that
flexibility that freedom that ability to
move on the mobility the untetheredness
of renting however i have a family my
wife and daughter and i know it's been
important to my wife and this isn't a
core value of mine to not own a house
right right it's simply a
static surface level value yeah a
preference maybe it is yeah and so when
we when we delineate our values you have
foundational values you have structural
values and you have surface values it's
a surface value for me i value renting
over home ownership yeah however some
people
value home ownership i will add a caveat
here there's no true thing as
homeownership in the united states yeah
what is oh yeah right cause if you don't
pay taxes the government will take your
house and it's pretty difficult to get
them to take your house from you but it
is certainly possible yeah right and so
i just want to throw that caveat out
there but let's talk about home
ownership what are my thoughts on it can
you afford the house is
a qualifying question yeah and i mean
monetarily but there are all those other
costs too right that's exactly it and
some of those costs are much higher for
some of us so like i have a friend who
is really really handy with things
actually you know jordan who just bought
a house uh he and his girlfriend um they
have a house together they're now living
and he's going through all of these um
renovations and painting and and he's
really really handy so he has the skills
but even there i think it's testing his
patience and his limits at this point
he's giving me a vigorous head nod he
spent the last week painting things
moving cabinets and oh wow and just uh
you know trying to fix up a house
when you're renting
none of those costs exist right however
sometimes there are people who really
enjoy fixing up the house repairing
things i envy those people so much
i really do like i wish i loved doing
the handiwork i will say like once you
do uh you know like a little chore or a
little something when when i'm complete
with it it feels so good like i'm glad i
did it but um during the process i'm
just like cussing and it takes me like
three times as long to like do something
because i don't know how to do it so i
gotta like youtube it and follow the
steps and anyway yeah i'd admire people
who love that that that housework stuff
and so for some people it's draining for
me and you i think especially for me
it's it's really draining to do stuff
like that yeah for other people it's
invigorating it's life-giving
and so if you're the type of person
where it's life-giving to repair things
fix things up redecorate things move
things around shift constantly
comfortable with change
then
owning a home might be a blessing for
you yeah for someone else it could
definitely be a burden right and for me
it tends to be a burden so i worked some
uh i worked out a deal with my wife and
i said hey i don't want to i want to
pretend that i'm essentially renting
this house we're just paying a mortgage
payment every month yeah now for me that
means being able to pay off the house
within 15 years ideally sooner not an
adjustable rate mortgage but a fixed
rate mortgage
and can i afford the payment and if not
then i can't afford the house if i can't
afford to pay it off in 15 years i can't
afford the house either and i because
ideally i don't want any debt the only
debt that i'm willing to go into in fact
i got a mortgage for this house it's the
only debt that i have at all
it's the only that is acceptable in my
own life
and so
what are the minimalist thoughts on
owning a home it depends on who you are
if it is a blessing if it's life
affirming for you then it can be a
wonderful thing if renting and having
that freedom of renting
is more
valuable to you what are your values if
you understand what your values are
that'll help you make that decision
because
for me freedom is incredibly important
so i look at this house i don't want to
be able to deal with anything if
if a pipe busts hey bex you deal with
the plumber
i'm paying the rent here so that you can
be the landlord of the house
i'm gonna go into details on the maximal
episode this week because she and i have
lived apart you know we've been together
for seven over seven years now and we've
lived apart this entire time and one of
the questions is are we still going to
live apart how are we going to manage
that because we don't want to live
together yeah i'll tell you man i bought
my first home at age 25
and i did it for all the wrong reasons i
was renting
my lease was up my rent was you know for
for dayton ohio it was pretty high i
mean centerville was kind of a ritzy
area and um yeah rent was a little
expensive and i i was told by a girl i
was dating at the time her her uh
stepfather was a realtor and he's like
oh you're throwing your money away you
know look at how much money you're
spending on rent you could spend that
same amount of money on a house payment
and then you're putting your money
towards something you've got equity
you're actually paying towards an
investment rather than throwing away uh
your money each month so
combine that with the house credit the
tax credit that they were offering at
the time i think when you bought a house
like you got six thousand dollars or
something i was like oh it'd be stupid
not to buy a house i'm throwing my money
away uh there's six thousand dollars i'm
leaving on the table
and man um i ended up losing in the end
of that like when i sold that house five
years later i lost uh over ten thousand
dollars on that house and uh yeah i mean
i did it for all the wrong reasons i
didn't really consider
you know what i was going to get for
buying this house i just was told here's
the right thing to do here's a couple
examples of why this is the right thing
to do and i just went into it i did not
do it very deliberately and that is it's
one of the most
biggest mistakes i've ever made in my
life and uh as far as like you know
money-wise goes um it was it was a a
lesson like it was an adult lesson i
remember feeling like when i had to
write that check to cover the difference
between when i sold it what the people
paid for it and when i and what i owed
on it i had to cut that check that was
um that hurt man that really really hurt
so let's talk about some of those signs
that you're talking about here that it
doesn't make sense to buy a house
one we already covered you can't afford
it i mean you can't afford the monthly
payment but two you can't afford the
additional cost the psychological cost
of owning a home the time the upkeep the
maintenance
the middle of the night the water heater
burst whatever it is yeah these are all
your problems now right and so if you
can't afford that cost that is a
tremendous
sign that oh i should avoid owning a
house right now buying a house right now
here's a third sign though if everyone
else is telling you this is what you
should do this is what i'm supposed to
do that doesn't mean they're telling you
directly although in your life in your
case they actually were telling you
directly but society is also telling you
directly that
to own a home is virtuous
and that is not true yeah uh owning a
home doesn't make you a better person it
doesn't make you more virtuous it
doesn't make you more complete it
doesn't make you
the best version of yourself right you
can be all of those things without
owning a home in fact a home could very
likely incomplete you yeah because it's
taking away time money resources energy
skills away from
more meaningful pursuits so i say more
meaningful and i mean more meaningful to
you because homeownership can also be
very meaningful for my wife
you know her having a garden in the
backyard and being able to take care of
a home and she enjoys getting up on the
roof and removing the leaves from the
roof and i'm like okay like i never ever
want to do that i'm not going to do that
yeah and understanding what your
boundaries are are really helpful in
making a decision yeah which actually
brings me to our next question here we
have a question from facebook cindy on
facebook
i'm a 59 year old divorcee living in
socal and have always rented but i still
have a dream of owning a home one day is
it logical to even consider home
ownership at my age i say it's not
logical to consider a 30-year mortgage
although our friend chris ryan says i
think that um the best time to go into
debt is when you're like 80 years old
take on that 30 or 40 year mortgage at
age 90. right and the weird thing is a
lot of banks will give someone who is 60
years old a 40-year mortgage or a
30-year mortgage fewer banks will do
that now than they would back in the
heyday of the audis yeah where they were
just handing out loans when i bought a
home at 22 i built a home now i grew up
poor i was four years removed from being
poor
i was still broke i didn't have a down
payment and they're like that's okay wow
zero dollars down um oh i'd be stupid
not to do it right yeah that's what i
told myself i put myself in a similar
situation to you ryan in my 20s where
we were underwater when the housing
market crashed my house value was my
house was valued about 80 000 less than
what i owed on the house yeah it was
similar to a car in that respect you buy
a brand new car and all of a sudden you
drive it off a lot and half the value is
gone in some cases yeah and i felt the
same way with the home that i built and
if i were to go back and learn all the
lessons i learned from that is i did it
too soon i did it because i was supposed
to do it
it was something that i could afford the
monthly payment on but i couldn't afford
a 15-year mortgage on it i could only
afford it because of no down payment
which is another another thing if i
can't put at least 20
down yeah then i'm not willing to take
on that burden by the because then you
have to pay pmi and there's other other
fees associated with this you're going
to end up spending more money as a
result but also keeping in mind i want
to be able to pay this house off as soon
as possible so i'm 59 years old by the
time i'm 69 or 65
i'd love to have that house paid off i
think it's one of the biggest benefits
of home ownership is not having to pay
a landlord every month you start to pay
the government every month or every
three months or every six months yeah
every year they they demand their
shekels yeah right
and they have a monopoly on violence so
i always give them my the money they
they ask for right this podcast took a
weird turn
and uh
but what i'll tell you is that
it doesn't matter what age you are
it buying a home is never
a 100 logical decision
because they're all you're a human being
and so there are emotions involved it
may be the most logical decision
to rent
or it might be the most logical decision
to buy depending on your circumstance
here's what i'll say is it's not the
most logical decision for me to share my
resources with my wife
logically it doesn't make 100 logical
sense
but
i'm not just a automaton right i'm a
human being my wife's a human being it
makes a lot more emotional sense
to be with my wife
than it does to just be on my own in
perpetuity for other people however it
might be a little bit different and so i
think your question
cindy is a bit incomplete here does it
make logical sense yeah probably
mathematically if you can figure out the
math then it will make logical sense for
you if you can afford it
but does it make emotional sense for you
not just what's going on in your head
but what's going on in in your heart
tom from facebook has a question for us
what is the price to rent formula and
how can we use it to decide whether
renting or buying is more appropriate
for us hmm podcast john i have a
article to put in the show notes here by
the way we've got podcast sean here and
other sean if you're watching this on
youtube or if you're just listening to
the audio version
you can vote in the comments we're
trying to decide is it other sean is it
sean two
is it new sean
or
is it professor sean
i'll let you vote on that in the youtube
comments and um
he's gonna be filling in for podcast
sean podcast john we're gonna talk about
this on the maximal episode this week
the private podcast in fact i think
we're gonna drag podcast sean on to the
camera yeah and uh we're gonna have a
conversation with podcast sean about
leaving los angeles we're still gonna be
working with him but he's leaving la
he's finally all grown up that's right
he
graduated that's right he's in his 50th
year right now i i texted him on his
birthday and i said welcome to your 50th
year he's like i'm not 50 yet i'm like i
know this is your 50th year
you just turned 49. although he looks 29
my goodness i know man i'm so jealous i
need his skin care routine oh whatever
man you still get carded for cough syrup
man and you're 40.
that's because i buy a lot of cough
syrup
all right anyway um yeah uh we have new
new sean here other sean sean two here
uh they will put a link one of the
sean's will put a link in
the show notes for this article ryan
this one is from
smartasset.com it's called price to rent
ratio in the 50 largest u.s cities i
just want to read this really quick
because depending on where you live and
i think this is a follow-up also to
cindy's question to a great extent
depending on where you live also
determines
whether or not it makes sense to
purchase a home what is the better
option right
and so it goes on to say the article
says depending on your circumstances
renting or buying a home can be a smart
financial decision home ownership
however
can help you home ownership can help you
build equity and lower taxes while
renting offers greater greater
flexibility and convenient services
keeping this in mind smart asset ranked
the 50 largest u.s cities according to
the price to rent ratio to calculate the
price to rent ratio
for the 50 biggest nationwide cities
nationwide we took a look at how the
medium home value correlates to the
medium medium and annual rent generally
a lower price to rent ratio means
conditions are more favorable for buying
a home and a higher price to rent ratio
means renting is favorable so we're
going to talk about some of these cities
here i'm not going to read the whole
article to you it's a long one but i
just want to go into this here here were
the key findings in the article ryan the
largest u.s cities are good for renters
san francisco new york san jose seattle
and los angeles are all in the top 10 of
this study and are all among the most
populous cities in the country i will
tell you this this is why bex and i
moved out of la county because she
really wanted to buy a home i supported
her in that decision we found homes that
we could afford and they weren't in this
neighborhood yeah in fact the home that
we bought outside of la county
is you couldn't even buy a piece a tear
down house in this neighborhood for
example there are studios in yeah
although i will say that our commercial
rent here is relatively inexpensive
relative to the home prices of the homes
that are just across the street yeah
that's that's different from the home
ownership conversation though
the second finding ryan is that renter
fit friendly cities populate california
while the midwest is better for buyers
of the 10 cities in our study where
buying a home is more favorable than
renting five or in the midwest the
median home value across these five
cities on average is only 137 000
wow so let's get into some of these
cities ryan when was this written this
is uh this is last year oh wow it was
less than a year old okay so um
cities where renting is more favorable
than buying a home here's the top ten
and i'll then i'll call out some
specifics in two of these cities san
francisco oakland
new york san jose los angeles seattle
long beach california which is l.a
washington dc san diego boston yeah all
major cities a lot of them are tech
cities as well i think if you expand
that to 20 cities or so you'll start to
see cities like miami creep up into
there maybe even nashville um
it kind of depends you know where the
housing market shifts significantly like
right now i saw this statistic
that uh the rent in the tampa bay area
where we own our coffee shop
we're in st petersburg bandit coffee
but uh the tampa bay area as a whole
had the highest rent increase and in
some areas of the tampa bay of tampa bay
67 rent increase year over year that's
insane
it's it's unsustainable right and so
what we're learning is some markets it
made more sense to rent for the longest
time but then the pendulum sometimes
swings
the other way yeah let's talk about two
of these cities ryan so number one on
that list cities where renting is more
favorable san francisco oh yeah
california is the first of three bay
area cities in the top five of this
study
the median home income
home value rather is 1.2 million dollars
that's essentially your average house
average 1.2 million yeah we're in the
midwest it's 137 000 that's right wow
and the median annual rent is 23 000
which is also the second highest but
it's still favorable more favorable to
rent in san francisco than to buy yeah
so if you are doing a 30-year mortgage
on a one-point was a three million
dollar house or two million whatever
that number was uh your
30-year mortgage payment not a 15-year
your 30-year mortgage payment which you
don't want to do if you can't afford to
pay it off in 15. yeah so uh that that's
gonna fall around like six thousand
dollars a month give or take give or
take a little bit
um where the average rent at twenty
three thousand dollars a year you're
looking at less than uh two thousand
dollars a month on average for rent so
like that's where
i think that's what that article is
trying to point out i was like hey you
can rent something for about you know
two grand a month or you can buy
something for about six grand a month
right and uh yeah not i mean yeah it's
it's hard to triple your
your rent and and make that payment uh
yeah i totally yeah i like how where
this article is going it makes a ton of
sense and especially when you start to
factor in the 15-year and then you also
factor in the taxes which are much
higher in california because you were
when i owned a house in in dayton for
example
you're taxed on the assessed value of
the house so i owned a house that was
worth about two hundred thousand dollars
the most recent house i own but the
taxes i think was for sixty four
thousand dollars oh wow yeah and so you
weren't taxed on what you could sell it
for but in california let's say you buy
one of these houses at 1.2 million
dollars
you're taxed on the 1.2 even if
it sold previously for 300 000 yeah as
soon as it sells for 1.2 now you're
taxed at 1.2 and that varies from state
to state so you have to check your local
state or even your local county yeah to
determine the the tax rate this is
really making me feel good about renting
in los angeles actually well in fact
that's the next city here that i have
listed number five on the list ryan for
where renting is more favorable than
buying los angeles has the fifth highest
median home value and with just around
seven hundred thousand dollars now i
will say this keep in mind that's that's
an average so that includes azusa and
compton and south central
and west hollywood and studio city and
burbank it has all of these different
areas this amalgamation of these 88
different communities right yeah and so
in some areas like this neighborhood
i saw a tear down home
a few blocks from here yeah 2.7 million
dollars for a tear-down home so you're
basically buying a piece of land that
you have to clear so there's that
additional cost and then you got to
build a house on top of it i mean that's
a
that sounds like a 5 million investment
to me
exactly yeah and so thinking about that
is
what
i mean that's that's unfathomable for
most of us oh yeah certainly for us yeah
anyone in this room except for danny i
think he comes from money
he just looks expensive he does he does
gold chain is that real he looks money
see
but um
what i will say is that that's one of
the big reasons that we couldn't buy a
home we're here where we wanted now
there are other reasons why we
moved out of los angeles county and i'll
talk about those on the maxwell episode
because ryan i want to talk to you about
the cities
where buying a home is more favorable
than renting oh yeah let's talk about
those cities here's the top ten detroit
memphis milwaukee el paso baltimore san
antonio philadelphia indianapolis kansas
city columbus ohio where's dayton ohio
on that list they're not in the top 50
cities but dayton is actually the second
most favorable city in the country for
uh cost of living and home price goes
into that substantially i did scranton
then
uh then dayton favorable for for
price but really nothing else how dare
you podcast sean get out of here
bleep that out new sean
all right so um
what i will say is that
yeah there are a lot of midwestern
cities are going to be on here that
don't fall in top 50. so places like
youngstown dayton akron
probably um grand rapids
or lansing
fort wayne indiana right
springfield illinois
springfield missouri
springfield massachusetts
springfield montana
no that's pretty expensive in montana
yeah they're not going to fall on this
list anyway you'll notice that most of
these
cities
in fact all of them except one could
argue el paso
are
east of the rockies
yeah because home prices and what
they're calling zoom towns these days so
zoom town during the pandemic a lot of
people moved out of major cities into
what people are calling zoom towns now
because they can
work from home yeah they can be on zoom
and work and so they could live anywhere
essentially that's right yeah so cities
like bozeman montana which is the
largest zoom town during the pandemic
bozeman
is
a place now where a lot of locals have
been priced out and missoula is similar
boulder colorado a lot of cities in the
west
in general the rockies and on the west
coast have been priced out because the
the people have been priced out because
the the home prices have just
skyrocketed and i'll talk about my
experience on getting denied on several
houses that we made offers on
i'll talk about that on the private
podcast as well but i want to get into
these cities ryan i'll jump in just real
quick josh so uh my wife you know works
at the post office sarah missoula yeah
uh talked to a guy that works at capex
which is one of the i think it's the abc
affiliate oh yeah we've been on k-pac
that's right yeah that's how we knew we
made it
but uh
he uh said his general manager bought uh
in missoula i want to say three years
ago bought a house for 137 000
it's now valued at 400 thousand dollars
yeah
wow it's crazy how much it's well the
pandemic has
just really messed with the housing
market situation yeah yeah it's nuts we
can talk more about it on the maximal i
would say the investment side of things
i'd be really careful about that and in
fact
when we think about
diversification you don't want all of
your money to be in your home right and
i think we'll have more time to talk
about that later when we're answering
some questions here but
when we're talking about diversification
if 90 of your
assets are in your home you may own your
home but then if the market tanks yeah
well now you don't have any assets that
are working for you in the stock market
so what's the uh house ownership to gold
ratio that i should own
a hundred or i guess one to zero
perfect yeah i don't own any gold i
don't own any commodities uh i don't buy
individual stocks either i'm not
suggesting that the reason i don't buy
individual stocks i put any of my money
in my retirement money in to index funds
right so s p 500 real boring stuff yeah
that i get to set and forget i just have
a monthly contribution going in in fact
we have a minimalist essay about
minimalist retirement planning we'll put
a link to that in the show notes as well
i feel like there's someone listening to
this right now and they're thinking
about how bad the stock market is and
they're trepidatious to like invest into
any index funds but like right now the
stock market is on sale yeah like it
will it will come back eventually so uh
yeah index funds just to your point like
that's the safer bet for sure it's a
little bit more risky than bonds like
bonds are like the absolute safest right
but you don't get a very high rate of
return in fact bonds typically don't
outpace inflation so exactly one might
argue that bonds are more risky in that
respect that's true but but you're right
i mean in terms of yeah can the stock
market tank and if you need immediate
access to your money like for example i
had a down payment for this house i
didn't leave that in the stock market
yeah as we were looking because i know
like uh oh what if the stock market goes
down 50 does my down payment go down 50
i can't afford that right exactly but if
i'm waiting
because all my money are in these 59 and
a half accounts
for the most part we have a sep array
which is like a self-employed
uh ira basically similar to a 401k and
and so
that's a 59.5 account i mean i'm not
going to touch the money i can't touch
the money until i'm at least 59 and a
half without receiving some sort of
penalty yeah anyway returning to these
cities ryan cities where buying a home
was more favorable than renting detroit
michigan was number one on that list
detroit has the lowest median home value
in our study only 59
000. and the fifth lowest median annual
rent which is ten thousand dollars so it
puts the price to rent ratio at five
point six seven so it is the best place
to
buy a home versus renting yeah makes
sense memphis tennessee was also on that
list it was number two
i mean yeah i think memphis is a bit up
and coming and you're gonna see you're
probably gonna see that flip more people
have been moving into
nashville and franklin and to a lesser
extent knoxville and chattanooga but a
lot of people especially the last couple
years have moved in
to tennessee yeah because they're
favorable in terms of taxes and capital
gains and and civil liberties and and
also a lot of the weather there if you
can tolerate the allergy season there
it's great yeah
relative to living in minnesota or
something right and so you don't have
those bitter cold winters in nashville
it still still gets gray in february and
in january and even december in
nashville nashville or memphis uh well
in tennessee
in general right but not nearly like it
is in dayton ohio for example right
anyway memphis has the second lowest
media home value after detroit it's a
hundred and sixteen thousand that's a
pretty big jump from 59 000 to 116 000
and also the 10th lowest median annual
rent so it makes a lot more sense to
rent there
and then this article one last thing
ryan let's pick out a few of these
cities this has the price to rent ratio
in the 50 largest cities in the u.s we
talked about san francisco being number
one on that list definitely makes sense
to
to
rent to rent in san francisco but there
are other cities right here in the
middle like minneapolis at number 18 or
colorado springs at number 19 or
albuquerque at number 26. these are
places that it's better to rent we don't
know it makes more sense to rent they're
in the middle right so number 50 is
detroit that's where it makes more sense
to buy number one is san francisco makes
more sense to rent but when you get to
the middle when you're at number 25
which is raleigh north carolina it's
like it's kind of up in the air
it really is up to you whether or not it
makes the most sense to rent or buy in
that city yeah i think when it falls in
one of those states like yeah you've got
to look at other values that you have
going on in your life but i think one of
those values is
how much do you value that community how
long do you plan on staying there
because if you don't see yourself if you
don't see yourself staying there more
than five years
then
you're not you're not going to make that
much money off your house in fact you
might be yeah you might be better off to
run that situation i think that's a
great point as well another thing to
look at if you're going to buy a home if
you're not going to be there for at
least five to seven years minimum yeah i
like to look at seven years i'm a little
bit more conservative with my money but
i will find that not like politically
conservative but i'm conservative with
with
my money i don't like to part with it as
much
thank you for the clarification yeah and
and so i don't like um
when i'm looking at at home prices i
don't
want to go into a transaction where it's
like oh yeah i'm going to be here for at
least a couple years because you're
probably with all the closing costs i
remember i had to come to the table with
so much money for closing costs all
these different things and it's like oh
wow i i'm not going to make any of this
back anytime soon it's a great point
buying a house is really expensive i
don't want to go through the closing
costs over and over again and they tend
to be relative to
your mortgage and and the price of the
home so the more expensive your home is
like if you're buying a three million
dollar home or a multi-million dollar
home i didn't buy a multi-million dollar
home but um if you're buying one like
that the closing costs are even going to
be higher yeah right mm-hmm
all right we got a voicemail here let's
move on to our callers if you have a
question or comment for our podcast give
us a call 406 219 7839 or email a voice
memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com looks like raz has a
voicemail for us
me and my girlfriend we're watching this
show now
about uh tiny houses and we were
wondering what's your view about those
personally i i found that i find them to
to go uh
way too far but
it's definitely a cure that some people
seem to do i think it's kind of cool so
what do you guys think
so i tend to agree with what raz is
saying here we
it's some people go way too far yeah for
me
but it's also
a concept that i really appreciate
tiny living intentional living i'm
somewhere in the middle i want to own
enough only enough things that will fit
into a tiny home but i don't want to
live in a tiny home itself yeah you know
for me the tiny home situation it's the
bathroom sich man
it's like you you can close the door but
you really don't have privacy in that
bathroom so it's almost like you need
two tiny homes one is just a bathroom
it's an outhouse yeah but a really nice
outhouse right exactly yeah with heated
floors yeah
right right and uh heated toilet seats
you know one of those japanese toilets
dude um
i uh yeah i and mariah have considered a
tiny house but we are
tall people
and but like our first documentary uh
minimalism we uh had a tiny house in
there
and um it was uh tammy right yeah tammy
strzok yeah tammy strobel and her
husband and i admired that so much it
was beautiful like every
little bit of detail that they had i
mean they just paid so much attention to
detail it was a gorgeous tiny home but
even in that gorgeous tiny home i'm like
oh man mariah and i would just like be
on top of each other which
i guess wouldn't be that bad
[Laughter]
for you
[Laughter]
but you know what i really appreciated
about their home though they lived in a
beautiful area
they had beautiful scenery shasta yeah
yeah mount shasta is just like yeah it's
a it's a it's a pretty amazing place but
uh what's really cool is that it just
made them spend more time outside which
is which is a good thing
um so you know for that aspect maybe it
is a good thing um but yeah tiny house
totally for it love it support it it's
beautiful i don't i want to own like a
simple home not a tiny home but like
just a simple home and that's what bex
and i have done with our home it's not
tiny by any stretch of the imagination
the the main house itself is
um about 1 400 1500 square feet it's a
three bedroom two bath
very simple plain in a very simple blue
collar up and coming neighborhood
and uh i got to meet some of my
neighbors we'll talk about that a little
bit during the lightning round as well
but also having access to nature where
the home is was also important to us so
we wanted to be somewhere where there
were mountains but we also had access to
the ocean if we wanted to drive there
and so that's important we obviously
can't afford a house on the ocean
or even on the side of a mountain but we
have access to these things
and so a tiny house in well st
petersburg florida probably makes a
whole lot more sense or in mount shasta
makes a whole lot more sense there than
it would in saskatoon right because in
saskatoon part of the year you don't
have full access to nature i mean you do
but you'll freeze to death there right
but it's going to be much more difficult
to freeze to death in mount shasta so
part of
the tiny home really has to do with its
environment the environment in which
it's placed because that becomes a giant
room for you your exterior is now
your part of your living situation yeah
and so for us that was important we have
a backyard it's not too big and although
we have this neighbor who has this giant
um
shed that is getting ready to fall over
on our fence so we're trying to figure
out that whole
situation still and uh you have to get
in good with the neighbor so you can
negotiate these these things
the tiny house thing the question is
like yes i really admire it but is it
appropriate for me no
the amount of things that fit into a
tiny home tends to be appropriate for me
i don't like to have a lot of things
because like a calm really simple space
but i also like to have more airiness
more space as well the biggest feature
the house we just moved into is that it
does have central air but it's
controlled by each room
and so you don't have to cool down the
whole house if it's really hot out you
can just cool down the bedroom at night
without cooling down the entire area so
you save money on that as well cool ryan
what time is it you know what time it is
it's time for the lightning round where
we answer your questions we read your
comments we read your smart remarks you
can send all those to 937-202-4654
yes indeed now during the lightning
round this will ryan and i do our best
to answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response
podcast sean he takes our minimal maxims
and he puts them in the show notes so
you can copy and share our pithy answers
on social media if you like and now you
can find all of our minimal maxims in
one place thanks to our good friend
jessica lynn williams minimalmaxims.com
looks like we got a question here from
esther what do we look for in
communities when we're ready to plant
roots you know it's funny the analogy
here planting roots seems like a very
empowering analogy right the one that's
in my mind quite often and this is why i
think i err on the side of renting
personally is it feels more like an
anchor than a root
i live in a i lived in a building now uh
recently that my neighbor i barely knew
them at all but they were real quiet
this russian older couple who were in
their 70s or maybe even in their 80s and
they were very very quiet anytime i
tried to talk to them they would just
kind of grunt a hello at me
and
i
to me they were like the best neighbors
in the world because they were loud they
never bothered me they never got into
any of my business yeah and it was it
helped
facilitate a calm environment so here's
my my pithy answer actually before i get
my pithy answer i've been reading a lot
of uh schopenhauer recently
and i found this quote of his that i
thought applied to this
what a man is contributes much more to
his happiness than what he has or how he
is regarded by
others
now
my pithy answer is this and here's how
they link up the quality of your
neighborhood is determined not by home
prices
but by the quality of your neighbors
yeah here's just a quick reminder for
you because we're all solipsistic to
some extent
also keep in mind you are someone else's
neighbor as well
it's not that everyone else is just
neighbors in the neighborhood yeah and
it's your neighborhood no you're also
their neighbor and this is one of the
the biggest selling points of the new
house that we bought is i got to meet
the neighbors on both sides and i pulled
up and the neighbor on one side
they had a sign on their porch
that said simplify for peace
i was like oh
yeah i found my people they're here
right and the other people i got to meet
them before we bought the house
and
they showed up and they were super kind
to me and ella and bex and inquisitive
and offering help if i got tools if you
ever need it if you
and i think that translates really well
into a pithy minimal maxim that you have
for us yeah man you know when i heard
when i read this question
um
i was kind of thinking like you know
it's
i don't know how to say this without
sounding like a jerk but
it doesn't matter too much like what the
community
is
because you know you kind of get what
you put into a community
and i there are certain things that we
want to look for in communities we want
to be in a safe neighborhood there are
certain little aspects
but you know if you bring your the best
version of yourself
then uh that community no matter what
you know what it is politically what it
is socioeconomically it could probably
be an awesome community for you so yeah
my pithy answer is ask not what your
neighbor can do for you but what can you
do for your neighbor
and that is what really is going to make
an amazing community because if you're
looking for a community to see what you
can take
then it's probably going to be a bad
experience yes but if you're looking at
a community and asking yourself what can
i give like that's going to create a
pretty awesome living situation ryan my
dad used to have a saying that was very
similar to what you had there
he said if you want good neighbors
be a good neighbor amen
tweet that podcast sean
what's your what you're talking about
here is a parasitic relationship versus
a contributing
yeah and the nice thing about
contributing is you tend to get things
back not with the expectation of quid
pro quo right but if you're a part of a
community and you're giving people tend
to be more giving toward you
by and large yeah and so when i met
those neighbors i can guarantee you the
people on the left side of my house
voted for joe biden and the people on
the right side voted for for donald
trump
in the last election and i don't care
yeah because that doesn't tell me about
who they are because if i'm being a
neighbor it doesn't matter to me who you
voted for right or what your political
persuasions are what your beliefs are
what your preferences are even
what matters to me is can i be kind to
you can i be compassionate toward you
and are you going to share that
compassion back with me yeah we put so
much weight on
you know who's who's who are the
senators who's the president um you know
this is a
this is a silly way to look at how
uh how our community is because
you're the president doesn't determine
how you treat each other yeah my
neighbor to the left a mirror to the
right of me has way more influence on my
life than the president does 100 because
if they're being super inconsiderate
they're out every morning with a
chainsaw at 5 30 a.m cutting things down
i think what it's going to do to my day
yeah much more than any politician can
do to my day amen and the opposite of
that is also true if i have a kind
caring neighbor
that often amplifies my caring my
kindness
and allows me to approach the world in a
more loving way yeah real quick uh right
here right now here's one thing going on
the life of the minimalist actually i
got two things we'll save one after the
comments but um ryan minimalist.org
about eight years ago we went to a
hundred different cities yeah and we
left behind a hundred free local meetup
groups
all over the world eight countries 100
different cities there's also an online
city if you don't have a city near you
as well and you've been working with
some of these community leaders they
tend to meet once a month and now
there's a monthly theme you want to talk
about some of those themes that we've
had recently yeah so now that some of
the regulations have been lifted a lot
of these groups are meeting in person
which i mean that's
that's the most powerful way to get
something from your community is go out
and meet people in person um so yeah
we've got we've got groups in the uk
ireland australia canada the united
states and we have been doing just these
different monthly themes so
may was digital minimalism and now in
june it is letting go
so if you want to like you know go and
meet some open-minded people like
yourself
and you want to see how other people
have let go if you want to share a story
about how you were able to let go um
check out those those in-person meetings
there's a there's a lot of value there
and then next month july it's financial
clutter or financial minimalism yeah
will be the topic and it's not limited
to those topics but that is sort of a
jump off point so you can talk about
material clutter for sure showing up at
these events getting best practices from
other people career clutter financial
clutter relationship clutter a lot of
clutter in our lives and these meetup
groups they're not all like-minded
people as we just discussed your
neighbors aren't going to all be
like-minded but what is really nice is
these groups have the open-minded people
yeah who are willing to see your
perspective see your point of view
without judgment without trying to drag
you or convince you toward their point
of view yeah i mean the whole point of
these groups were to really provide
support in-person support to these local
communities and i just want to say like
there's no agenda it's not like every
single group is talking about the same
bullet points at every single meeting
and that's what i kind of like about it
is each community kind of has its own
thing going on so like you said the
topic of letting go of the topic of
finances it's more of a jump off point
it's not like uh you know you and i
don't sit here and outline like okay
here's what you have to talk about at
each meeting yeah yeah we we provide the
foundation
they're your groups they're not ours we
just left them behind in all of these
cities you can find all of them over at
minimalist.org
we got a bunch more to talk about ryan
but first alabama you got something for
us here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners
hi my name is katie from sioux falls
south dakota i was really close with my
grandma who passed away probably about
12 years ago and i ended up with a lot
of her jewelry because that was what i
played with as a kid
and as i've gone through my minimizing
journey i've decided to keep
one thing and it's her class ring from
1948. i wear it every day in fact that's
too small now i can't even take it off
and everything else i have let go and
that way i can always keep her with me
however i don't have the
burden of all of her other jewelry
hi my name is adrian and i'm from
raleigh north carolina um you guys were
talking about meditation and how it
could
possibly lead you to a dark place if you
have never done that before
and you spent like maybe a long time in
meditation and i just
have a lot of insight into that i just
wanted to share that yes it could
bring yourself to a dark place
however for me personally i was ever
able to uncover a lot of
traumatic events that i've suppressed
since childhood through meditation and
although that led me to a very dark
place initially it led me to where i am
now which is a much happier version of
myself
so i just wanted to share that for
listeners who may be turned off by that
idea
um i think that it is worth it so to
meditate
all right y'all before we get to a fun
added value segment this week here's a
sincere comment from one of our lovely
patreon subscribers ryan brooke said
this she wrote in she said i stumbled
across your podcast by accident
i've been working in a high stress
career as a real estate agent where i
feel so much pressure every day recently
i started to feel a massive void and
even though i earn over 200 000 a year
wow i found myself with only
700
to my name i can relate with that amen
which put put me into a spiral of
despair i can relate with that as well
yeah then i started listening to your
private podcast i've been a listener for
a few months now and have already
started a transformation within myself i
began limiting my exposure to negative
and toxic clients so that i could
prioritize my time with my family i
found your private podcast at the right
time literally within 48 hours of
hitting rock bottom
thank you both for helping me let go um
i wanna talk about letting go real quick
danny maybe this will make a good tick
tock we'll see here but um
letting go is not something you do
it's something you stop doing and people
often ask how do i let go i'm not
struggling letting go of my couch or my
excess clothes or all of these things in
my cabinets my storage locker i just
can't let go so let's do a breathing
exercise ryan we'll do it together here
all right i want you to breathe in deep
and hold it
all right now what do you have to do how
do you let go
[Music]
i don't know
[Laughter]
the key is there is no how-to
it's the letting go it's the exhale
it's something you stop doing you stop
holding your breath
that's how you let go and the same thing
is true with any of our material
possessions or toxic relationships or a
toxic career or toxic clients
you simply stop holding on you stop
clinging that is how you let go
brooke thank you so much for your
comment another right here right now
segment here's one more thing going on
in the life of the minimalist ryan and i
are having a measuring contest
[Laughter]
what are we measuring again
well um in just a few days we are going
to be at the daytime emmys if you want
to check your local listings i don't
know if our segment is going to air or
whether or not we will win i just put
out this essay called for your
consideration you're we'll put a link to
that in the show notes as well talking
about sort of my mixed feelings about
being nominated for an emmy yeah for our
most recent netflix film less is now
and on one hand it's really great to get
acknowledged especially because it
breathes new life into the film but on
the other hand like awards for art seem
a little strange to me sure it's so
highly subjective and abstruse it's art
right who gets to say well this is great
art and this isn't and so i am grateful
for it i don't need it we're not
clinging to it but we are going to go
get measured for tuxedos
that's what we're measuring okay
[Laughter]
oh you know it's kind of like you know
the whole new york times bestselling
thing i mean it's not why we do it it's
not something that in fact i actually
don't like talking about it because it
feels a bit braggadocious yeah but the
accolades are pretty cool i mean it's uh
i can appreciate
the recognition for what it is
but
you know those rec those accolades do
not make or break me as a man let's talk
about that real quick because i feel a
bit more allergic to the new york times
best-selling thing
then i do to the emmy thing interesting
but i i know that they're all well
here's why the new york times best
selling thing
purports to be
subject or objective right yeah but we
all know like i'm thinking about our
most recent book love people use things
was a technically a new york times
best-selling book right but our second
book everything that remains probably
sold 70 times more copies in that book
right and it's not a
new york times bestseller because we
didn't play the same game yeah yeah and
i mean it's all kind of bs though like
because with the emmys it's the same
thing it's like our film minimalism
um you know has gotten millions and
millions of views um it's beautifully
directed it's it's uh you know same
director as les is now
a little bit different of a team
production team but long story short
like it's the same exact thing we
weren't nominated for anything with that
first documentary because we
independently published it so it is all
it is all kind of bs yeah yeah and but
as soon as you recognize that you can
see the specialness of the whole thing
you can realize like oh i appreciate
what this is doing for the film
it doesn't have to do anything for my
own ego or my hubris i don't need to win
we can go there we can just be happy
that the thing was nominated i don't
need that either i'm not going to cling
to it but i'm also not going to renounce
it and that's what you've really helped
me with right not renouncing any of
these things because as soon as i
renounce it oh ba humbug well now i'm
tied to it the same way scrooge is tied
to christmas right or the grinch is tied
to christmas as well right yeah oh
ba-hum but i can't i'm going to renounce
this well now that defines who i am and
so not renouncing it but also not
clinging to it yeah holding it loosely
and always being prepared to let go
ryan it is summertime now for our added
value this week i have a song for you
when we move to our new house ella and
bex and i were listening to this album
all weekend just driving around the
small town
and uh through the mountains went over
to the beach for a while
and oh this album ben rector
he has new album called out it's called
the joy of music and this song is called
it would be you and it is some of the
greatest upbeat summertime music enjoy
the song from
ben rector here's it would be you by the
way ryan we got a bunch more surprise
questions this week like
there's an overwhelming amount of
knowledge needed when it comes to home
buying like taxes zoning maintenance
hoas financing insurance where are you
supposed to learn all this well ryan i
got two places you can learn and we'll
tell you where what are the pros and
cons of full-time rv living tiny houses
condos and other non-traditional living
options what are the pros and cons of
renting out extra space on platforms
like airbnb and vrbo we'll talk to ryan
about that because he has a
home that he rents out on
airbnb regularly what are the benefits
of buying locally versus shopping online
plus a million more questions for the
minimalist we're also going to drag
podcast shawn onto the podcast to give
him a farewell from los angeles if you
want to hear all that check out the
minimalist private podcast this week
visit patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain immediate access to
hundreds of hours of private archives
recordings of live events exclusive home
tours and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you
you can follow the minimalists on tiktok
instagram facebook and twitter follow
podcast sean at podcast sean
if you want our podcast show notes in
your inbox curated by podcast sean sign
up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus podcast sean other sean or
sean too or new sean
alabama jordan no more social just danny
unknown post-production peter emma the
immigrant and the rest of our team i'm
joshua fields milburn if you leave here
today with
just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for being here y'all we'll see you next
time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it